high upon the mountains of Southern
Ecuador a sinkhole opened in the earth
one night late last year
is
the hole measuring some 90 feet across
and 100 feet deep consumed several
historic homes that night and left
scores more uninhabitable
it was the product of one thing and one
thing only gold mining
these in case
[Music]
the cement holding back the hillside
behind me is an emergency measure
designed to keep the massive sinkhole
I'm standing at from swallowing more of
the historic gold mining town of saruma
zuruma sits atop bullion Rich rock some
of the finest in the world
a run-of-the-mill commercial Gold Mine
only spits out around three or five
grams for each ton of dirt mined that's
like finding a few grains of rice in two
thousand pounds of Earth 8 grams per ton
makes the mine high grade category
under zaruma there are veins that yield
500 grams a ton
this is an illegal mine entrance
shuttered by the government
for about a thousand years back before
even the Incas arrived people have been
mining the area for gold
Yvonne Nunez a top engineer has been
brought in to stabilize the town but he
admits that officials don't know where
all the digging is happening
foreign
exactly
[Music]
as the price of gold and all sorts of
other metals copper cobalt silver
tungsten has soared so too has illegal
mining
it's an industry worth tens of billions
of dollars globally and much of the
metal slips into Global Supply chains
and ends up in smartphones televisions
and laptops it's just too lucrative for
Outlaw miners to pass up and they're
willing to risk it all
verification
stretchfield
as a legal mining goes unchecked the
underground tunnels become more and more
dangerous the first sinkhole opened up a
few years ago under a school forcing the
evacuation of 300 children
ellios
yes
foreign
there's also damage happening to more
than just the city streets mining as
polluted waterways with Mercury sodium
cyanide and other toxic chemicals
after the December sinkhole president
Guillermo lasso sent in the military to
stop the illegal miners but with so many
secret entryways the sableros keep
pouring in
which leaves the task of stabilizing the
damage caused by the tunnels up to Nunez
filling these Caverns sounds simple it's
anything but
his team will drill large Wells that
will then be packed with cement Rock and
Sand
this he figures will both stabilize the
ground and block off the key arteries
the sableros depend on but many say that
only one thing could stop the sableros
if zaruma runs out of gold
foreign